hello it is a team adieu ensure and the
team is out this week but I'm here to
talk about the SNL controversy with
Sandy givers Shane gear is in my
favorite comedian and he was going to
build SNL and now a st. Gilles is not
going to be on SNL and it is a such a
dishonor um hello everybody
that was an Asian accent was not great
but it was the accent of an Asian male
that was the accent but I was chilling
when did accents become a sign of
disrespect and I mean that like if you
imitate at one point they said imitation
was the sincerest form of flattery which
i think is kind of true because you're
putting in obviously some type of effort
to try to mimic somebody now obviously
you're not always flattering somebody
when you mimic them we get that but when
did it become like horribly offensive to
imitate somebody else that was not of
your race I understand the thinking
behind that to a degree you know but I
think people's voices are funny right
like I have a funny voice when people
imitate me like Matt Wayne who's a comic
in New York City is a great imitation of
me where it's just you know everything
that I would say was a hey kid Gail you
know the other day because a lot of my
friends I took about my friends by their
last names like I have friends named
like Morris or Clark so when Matt Wayne
imitates me he'll be like you know we
was with Morris o'clock you know
Donatelli you were all out we having a
rib eye it's my favorite cut and I
always tell myself and it's funny
because I have a ridiculous voice like
it's a [ __ ] crazy voice
that I have you know I mean there was a
woman I knew in the mortgage game she
had a wild voice she was West Indian she
liked teens you know these things I
don't understand and when she said
something with that voice was very funny
like one day she goes I the bank trying
to make me take the bars off me windows
because they don't think I can get out
in a fire and pay them their money she
was right and I'm like whoa
why do you want the bars on your windows
I was like I don't have bars on my
window she's like but if somebody tried
to get you you're big and fat you can
fight what's a little ice made it funny
it the woman had more money than me she
was smart she was savvy she owned
multiple home like dude I'm not making
fun of her I just think it's fun like
the way she said it in his no-nonsense
way and it's the way she said I'm not
making up the way that she said it
that's the way she sounds it's my
approximation of it I'm doing the best
job I can but this idea that it's like
inherently disrespectful to imitate the
ethnic accent of somebody else I don't
buy that I don't know why that's a thing
I understand why people think it should
be a thing I think their logic is off
but I'm confused as to why and you say
oh you're a white guy in society you've
held these privileges and sort of make
fun of people that have had less
privileges than you
Asians are doing good West Indians are
doing good like African immigrants are
doing well they have higher than average
incomes your employment numbers are
higher so this whole punching up
punching down if you look at the raw
data and the numbers people are doing
okay out there
it's not like I'm not saying Disney
should go remake song of the south and
have all these [ __ ] racist
characterizations of black people but
I'm saying if you're imitating the way
somebody sounds and you're trying to you
know you try to repeat a funny anecdote
and I'm gonna get it Shane you know
Shane Gillis was fired from SNL friend
of mine very funny guy said some things
on a few podcasts you know people dug it
up I think it's the first instance and I
could be wrong and maybe Ben you can
correct me I think it's the first
instance of somebody getting in trouble
from a podcast right um yeah I think
you're right actually
yeah it's usually a tweet yeah you're
right usually a tweet will do it a
little dab'll do ya little tweet will do
it usually a couple of tweets you know
cuz Leslie Jones never said shanked by
the way doing 20 years of road comedy
she never said [ __ ] on the road to get
a laugh and don't think she did don't
think she did I trust me
what'd you say to gonna laugh half the
time comes from desperation you're
trying to fill time trying to get a
laugh and sometimes the most shocking
thing is funny because it's taboo and
I'm not gonna rehash all of this because
I know that you know we all know this my
listeners know it we get it you know
this isn't new it's been going on for a
while
comedies this cultural battleground that
people are using comp because no one
cares about comedy
SNL like people care about it only when
they can use it as a battering ram to
bludgeon each other on either side of
the ideological divide that's why they
care
it's not a big deal unless there's blood
and the wood is chumming the water
everyone's like wow that's it's a big
deal and I've know it pairs I do comedy
or all over the country and people go to
a comedy show cuz there's nothing better
to do and they enjoy it we have a lot of
[ __ ] fun it is not the be-all and
end-all of their life they are not
leaving go bananas in Cincinnati with a
new view on the world they're just not
that's not where you go to get
perspective the idea that it is wild coz
what Carlin and hey you want to point to
the five most brilliant people that have
ever done it okay
that's not a good standard yeah but
Hicks made people think yeah okay we'll
give you that a few specials absolutely
amazing but even then I had uncles that
loved Carl and then they went voted for
Reagan it doesn't stand doesn't matter
nobody's changing their opinions about
it but we know this even as I say it I'm
bored it's boring it's not logical you
try to talk to these people and they're
there illa B because people are living
in the fantasy land that what they do
matters so you can't talk to people like
that because it's like talking to
children who are really invested in a
game they're playing and you go you got
to come in and eat dinner and they're
like no but it's almost over we ought to
do it and you go no no it doesn't matter
you'll play it tomorrow
you're not playing for anything real
it's it's fake you don't even like these
kids on the block you're playing man up
with them because you're bored now get
in here any [ __ ] dinner before I kill
you
that's who you're talking to you're
talking to an eight-year-old who goes no
it's taking me so long I'm finally up at
bat now one more in
no go to bed it doesn't matter it'll be
there tomorrow everything is going to be
there this isn't the moment do you
understand but they don't think like
that these people are living in a
fantasy world with inner marching with
dr. King they they're out of their minds
they think they're marching would
Malcolm X like what are you doing you're
doing cabaret dinner theater in in
what's left of the village in Manhattan
you're performing for bankers at Goldman
Sachs and you'd think that you're like a
revolutionary like you're a guerrilla
fighter trying to take down the power
structures I it's unfathomable to me I
like Shane I don't know Shane that well
but what what I know of him I like him
he's a good guy he's a beast of a comic
and he earned his way on that [ __ ]
show by the way by having great sets and
having a great audition and that's how
he [ __ ] got that show you got jfl and
they got cluster fest in San Fran and he
killed it killed in front of liberal
crowds he killed in front of the people
that are supposed to [ __ ] matter he
went up and murdered and then he went in
front of Lorne and he didn't succumb to
the pressure he [ __ ] knocked his
audition out of the park and then he
[ __ ] got on the show